this is right around the corner so I
thought I'd invite a friend to teach us
how to decorate for the holidays a lot
of late night shows and daytime shows do
that kind of thing they bring in someone
to teach you how to decorate for the
holidays so this lady she's got her own
do-it-yourself YouTube channel she went
away for about a year she had some
issues but she is back now and I think
doing a lot better
please welcome melodie crafts let's see
melodie classic okay melody doing
anything interesting for the holidays
yes so today we're gonna be decorating a
gingerbread house in my experience all
gingerbread houses can look the same so
to make mine stand out I like to add a
little gingerbread family that's
adorable it's not beautiful that's great
yeah you can even give your family
little accessories like a hat or a rusty
knife Wow why would you want one of them
to have a knife just in case and keep in
case of white and then I like to take
some powdered sugar and let it snow
a lot of snow enough snow to hide things
what things are we hiding and you ever
have to stick to gingerbread houses
for example you can make a gingerbread
courtroom oh then you can make a
gingerbread court mandated therapists
office then oh you can make a
gingerbread psychiatric hospital because
they said you'd be a danger to yourself
and others if you went to gingerbread
prison excuse me I'm sorry are those
animal bones on the top those look like
animal bones
good point Conan then when you're done
decorating a cute finishing touch is to
set everything on fire no no don't do
that
that's a bad idea don't do that don't
light it on fire yeah that'll show those
doctors who secretly have a crush on you
but won't admit it
I'm glad I put out the fire that started
it rehearsal but didn't start here
nobody claps everybody why do we have
you back with a great show from the new
movie bombshell John Lithgow's here
within a break we'll be right back
you